hi there
today i want to talk a little bit about
time you know i often say that there's
three elements in language learning it's
there's your attitude there's the time
with the language and then
being attentive
and that three kind of are interrelated
i mean the more the
more positive the attitude the more time
you spend the more time you spend the
more you notice the more you notice the
more you get motivated the more you're
motivated
but i think one of the key elements is
time where do we find the time how do we
make the time
you have to develop habits and when you
have habits where you start finding the
time
that improves your attitude improves
your ability to notice so time is kind
of a key element
and a lot of people say i have no time
so i i think we have to look at ways
that we can create time and there's two
things that i would say very quickly
before i get into some of the sort of
where i was today kind of thing
number one obviously wherever you can
listen listen so whether it be like
yesterday i went skiing
uh you know it was a half an hour up
there half an hour back that's an hour i
skied for an hour and a half cross
country skiing and there's three and a
half hours
what'd i say two and a half hours at any
rate
it all adds up if you can listen in the
car and so forth it all adds up
um
the other thing that i've started doing
and i can't really show it to you but i
have a little app here
on my computer
my computer on my iphone
but you can also put on your computer
and it's called a tracker and so every
time i start to listen or read or
something i start it and then when i'm
finished i stop it and what it does it
it forces me to stay on task because
i've started this listening thing i
don't want to be interrupted i've
started reading i won't go and do my
email
so these are different ways because when
you're in a classroom the teacher kind
of forces you to do stuff when you're
studying on your own it's more difficult
to have the discipline to really make
sure that you either find the time or
make the time at any rate today
i would play hockey again this morning
and then i went and drove out to a
korean mall
to have lunch
and us i was going to visit my bookstore
because there's a very nice lady there
but unfortunately i walked in the
bookstore and there was this guy with
his l.a cat pulled down over his head
still wearing his
outdoor jacket looked very un
welcoming korean guy i guess and i said
he's not going to talk to me in korean
and so i uh left and i will go back to
that bookstore when the nice lady is
there
and uh so enjoy the rest of the video is
over people are coming down
off the mountain
and uh
slowly getting darker so i'm gonna head
home this is where the downhill area is
not too much snow this year
normally we'll have three four meters of
snow
uh then we turn around
there's of course you know the parking
lot and so forth it's known as cypress
bowl because there's lots of cypress
trees here uh it's hard to make out what
it is right now and
here of course off in the distance
above the clouds
you can just see the sun
setting it's around 4 30 or so i think
which is getting close to sunset here
and some people are going into the trail
again
i am at the korean mall
um gonna have a korean lunch and then
there's a bookstore here which i'm gonna
visit
maybe chat up the lady in the bookstore
in my limited korean
but all the shops here are korean
uh even i might just go to this uh
restaurant here i'm walking backwards
hope i don't hit a car
this restaurant advertises itself as
well i'll show you on a separate video
inside this uh korean restaurant i
ordered salon
which is some kind of a beef soup
those gentlemen are speaking chinese i
don't know if i'm gonna go over and
bother them or not
but uh here we have it
we'll see what my korean food tastes
like
um
um
you know you got to get into it this
this broth is delicious
the kimchi is excellent absolutely
delicious a little bit of rice here
and what's typical of the korean food of
course is the metal chopsticks
and that kind of gets me in the mood
restaurant
um
um
now i gotta rush off and study some
korean
been charging around and i've been
making this video and editing it
and i'm running out of time so but i
want to ask you people out there how do
you find the time how do you make the
time how much time do you have for your
language learning how do you fit it in
let's get some comments and ideas on
what we can do to find more time